yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing horny tax again just like
yesterday it's kind of screwed up is
raiding it was like 100 points higher or
something yes the day ok so we got him
yeah what about you what would you call
that okay that's probably Queens pawn
technically no anyway it's oh this is a
lot of bad line for black at home I have
played this myself occasionally in blitz
never in tournament Chesson for no
particular reason simply didn't happen
yeah the problem here with the whites
position is that problem is a bit strong
with the weight if I do that it takes
Knight Seto
hmm see home
if it takes that I can go Knight e5
maybe like takes Knight takes Knight c2
rupee one night before looks like it
could be a problem
yeah he just covers that eyelid is
probably not too bad like covering d5 I
mean so hmm yeah let's go for Queen b3
Bishop d2 yeah one main issues for white
that I have no control over a form due
to this weird night before thing you
know I simply have no control of it
before I can never play this really and
yeah it makes it a little bit difficult
that you I get something going okay so
maybe maybe c5 now is an idea for white
I mean not for black for black c5 would
be way a way to lose I mean I have a
better development here though what
black is doing is some strategically
justified but a bit slow still it's not
certain that I'm really threatening c5
maybe he can just play b6 and be okay
that is actually very likely so yeah I
would probably also have gone from
Knight f6 yeah true belong say anyway so
let's do it
I have a happen somehow yeah kind of a
deja vu going on like that the right way
to pronounce it I feel like I've had
this on the board perform now invited to
is a very lame move
so if I go see five now yeah probably
just be six him
hmm okay
hmm I don't really see what to do I mean
not like I'm lost or anything but what
is my move yeah maybe okay III
[Music]
usually I switched it off and now a
styling video and I get a call
[Music]
all that is long but what what on earth
can be so important probably nothing
okay so yeah
okay so now he is ready to play
c5 finally but I have some ideas now I
have got f3 for now and it's not so easy
factor to do all the things he needs to
do I have six I go 93 and that's a
reasonably good position for the night
you know I can't go to the 7 but I am
probably not a good idea
so now I'm threatening f3 now okay and
from now on it's all backwards
I think if ye goes back Bishop f2 92 and
so on I've got a big center while there
is something that I don't see that's
possible
why is he not just going to d6
taking a long time I think for somewhat
forced moves
okay now night c5 comes into
consideration of course but I can't
simply oh is that not really bad I can't
go to c3 as well but I think t2 is good
maybe I should have gone gone to c5
before he goes 97 yeah that probably
would have been a good idea but I'm not
unhappy here the position is fine oh
that's a pawn
threatening d5 a little bit of a side
threat yeah now that looked okay for
black for for the most part but somehow
it was was kind of tough
somebody says engine who who's the
engine not me anyway
and blacks not an engine that did him
they're very sure
okay so we got we got this which which
seems kind of normal the engine says
it's roughly equal yeah I kind of
believe that so
yeah he who neat access he expected me
to play c5 yeah but but this is fine
this is really just fine
what what can I do here this is good for
black probably and and here black is
also perfectly okay something like this
must be fine I have too many weird
pieces yeah I think what he probably the
engine actually likes D takes so this is
still okay but somehow somehow it went
went astray I'm actually surprised that
okay Knight c4 is stronger that is that
is certainly true we have now that I see
a I'm threatening this and threatening
this is better yeah 93
I wonder the engine thinks black is fine
but I don't think that this can be ever
equal no and now it gives want an
advantage 92 wasn't wasn't as accurate
okay with well the time cannot do
everything right but I think this this
must be better for wider a forum mm-hmm
f was interesting I'm preventing him
from going a for himself and I'm taking
the square way it's not so relevant that
this is technically weakened because he
has nothing to put down and I control
the square and that is probably a good
move Knight b5 and black is better why
because because this is this is just to
lose okay so there were a couple of
inaccurate moves and this 22 was
actually really
take in a crew that's really too nice I
should be somewhat substantially better
actually and after 92 I'm worse yeah
okay there was a there were some time
scramble things but yeah okay blundered
a five and now our black is indeed lost
Cordy 5 wasn't the best yeah well but it
wins right oh why isn't that
yeah I'm goning the exchange so it is
it's a good move
yeah a bit bit odd and bit odd from here
it somehow went backwards and I think
that sometimes it's overestimated as
some overestimate or wrongly evaluated
as pieces on the back rank I mean it
could look like that this is a bit
strange from pure purely if you look at
just where the pieces are positioned
black looks active but the problem is
that he has no foothold in the center
and I can push them back long term so I
think it is quite clear that what is a
bit better here but it's it's nothing
and it shouldn't be substantial Bishop
g5 is not very intuitive what the engine
wants to do here okay III can maybe take
so I have to move it and then the engine
wants to go back yeah yeah I'm better I
mean it's just I mean the engine just
gives you a point something but it is
just much easier for white to play
because you know you push your your
Center on black it's just sitting there
that's simply for whites you play ok
guys thanks for watching